Let's consider the following
decision problem.
>From an initial state, we have a choice
of three actions, a, b, and c.
The immediate reward associated
with each of these actions is zero.
But these three actions will
take us to different states with
different possible rewards
available from these states.
Action a takes us to state S1,
from which our only
action is to loop at each
step back into state S1,
accruing a reward of P1,
which is a parameter, each time.
If we take action b
at the initial state,
we will spend the rest of the game
alternating between states S2 and S4.
We will gain a reward of P2 each
time we move from state S2 to S4.
And we will receive a reward
of P3 on the return trip.
And if we take action c initially,
we will move into state S3,
from which our only next action is to
move into state S5, attaining no reward.
After that,
we repeatedly loop in state S5,
attaining a reward of P4 at each step.
Suppose the game has an independent
probability, of ending after each step?
And, let's call this probability,
1 minus gamma, so
that the effective discount factor for
the scenario is gamma.
Given the parameters P1, P2, P3 and
P4, our problem is to determine for
which values of gamma we
prefer the initial action a,
the initial action b, and for which
gamma we prefer the initial action c.
We will solve this problem by setting up
a Markov decision process encapsulating
this state diagram in Burlap.
We will then run value iteration
procedures on the MDP for
different values of gamma in
order to answer this question.